and they're the people who live the
longest and we have like you know
countless
we have an abundant amount of data that
proves this
countries that eat low levels of
and high levels of live for a very long
time and they're leaning
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's the perseverance aspect too like
we're more willing to stick through with
things that we set out with an intention
it's impossible to have empathy for
others if you're not patient so i'm
going to bless you for that first of all
i agree with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing stocks shares
bonds you want to be investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic hamza andreas zorces we will go
in with our final three with brother
angel
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
welcome to the realist podcast in the
dunya with the three muslims
[Music]
let's keep uh the pareto principle in
mind 80 20.
just give us the most high-yield things
that our lay audience might want to know
that want to take their
body to i guess the sunnah physique keep
everything cool
and it doesn't need to be exactly what
you're currently doing it's just what
you recommend for majority of the lay
population
well i'd recommend number one
intermittent fasting
don't eat more
than in in don't eat more than an eight
hour window so i like to eat between 10
a.m and 6 p.m
all your food should come within a
window now if you can't do eight out
sometimes i do a four hour window
sometimes i do a two hour window i'm
going to eat between 10 a.m and 12 p.m
that's it i'm eating for for two hours
that's it
and i'm gonna fast the whole day after
of course sometimes we do dry fast like
during ramadan we're not eating
for for a prolonged period of time
but in terms of fitness and body
composition it's also very effective to
just eat for a few hours a day
and fast for i would say 20 hours in a
day
or 16 hours in a day you need to fast to
a certain level
why there's something called autophagy
autophagy is it's a greek term it comes
to origin is from a greek term which
means to eat your own body
when your body digests itself it's had
enough hours of digestion that it could
start to digest itself it always starts
with the
toxic cells okay now i'm not a doctor
i'm just trying to pair it here what
doctors say
that one japanese
professor won the nobel prize for this
uh sorry japanese scientists won the
nobel prize for proving autophagy it's
one of the most healthiest from what
i've read okay i've read the books of
i'm
um
his name he's the guy we used for george
i'm forgetting his name now he's a
famous uh
author uh he wrote the uh
everything you need to know about
fasting excellent book i'm sorry i'm
forgetting his name now my apologies
uh
it's so important to fast i feel i feel
like whenever i don't fast when i when i
just go back to regular eating and
sometimes i take a break from fasting i
always get
i always get
i'm always more lethargic i'm always
weaker i'm always i feel older like i
feel like i gain age but when i go back
to my fasting regularly
i feel like i
i feel amazing i feel younger i feel
like my my stomach now is
is resting
i feel
energetic i feel more clear of mine if
you fast long enough and intensely
enough you will start having um
something will happen something special
can happen to your your alertness your
level of cognitive ability
i'll leave that as a surprise for you
okay but there's definitely it'll take
you to another level you have to do it
long enough
you have to do it intensely enough now i
don't recommend too intensive fasting
like don't go
um you know five days without food i
don't recommend that okay now i know
some people who do that like no i've
never done five days but i have a friend
of mine and george shapiro actually he's
literally we're on the mat today was
telling me he's fasting he's doing a
three-day fast and i was like that's way
too much he's insane and he's training
and he's training but he's like no i
like it it's good because he had he had
a disease called colitis and they cured
him
jason fung is the author he went to was
treated by the man named jason fung the
man who wrote the book everything you
need to about fast fasting fantastic
book
and he cured george just with fasting no
drugs no
no medication
so george is always
on on
these fasting cycles to make sure that
his ailments stay at bay
now i feel that
my wife had romeo thorough arthritis she
helped she healed herself also with
fasting
she takes no medication whatsoever
her doctor said she's the first patient
she's ever seen cure herself with just
diet alone
so diet is very very powerful
it's extremely powerful let food be your
medicine let medicine be your food
as uh
hippocrates said
i believe number one is you should do
intermittent fasting number two
is
what you eat
it doesn't mean because you fasted for
20 hours that you should eat you know
all the junk food in the world no no
that's just gonna undo everything you
did you need to eat correctly
now what are the correct foods i'm not a
vegan but i heavily lean towards vegan
foods and there's an abundant amount of
research that shows it's very very good
for you now
i still eat meat i love steak my
favorite food is steak i still eat meat
but i want to eat meat once or twice a
week
i don't want to eat meat every day i
think in the west we're too culturalized
to eat meat every single meal every
single day
you gotta have animal product every
single day every single meal has to be
some type of animal product
i think that if people cut out animal
products they're going to discover that
their body feels incredible
you're just happy to be alive you just
have this energy this great feeling not
there's a detox period
if you quit smoking if you quit coffee i
don't care what you everybody has their
detox period and everybody's detox
period is different but once you get off
animal products
or once you minimize them i should say i
do believe animal products are important
i don't believe that you should come off
animal products completely i think that
is you have to really know what you're
doing if you want to go zero animal
products you got to be an expert in
nutrition if you want to get off
animal products at 100 you got to really
know your stuff
i think you need some animal products
five to ten percent as prescribed by dr
joel furman his opinion
five to ten percent of your calories
should come from animal products not
more not less
because when i tell people eat less
animal products they take it as don't
eat any amount of products that's not
what i'm telling you eat some animal
products have a steak once a week
sometimes i don't have a steak for two
weeks
but every day i eat beans lentils rice
vegetables some fruit
i really like
the uh
john mcdougall diet he calls it the
starch solution i'll put it in the
now
every diet you can you can overeat in
every diet
i highly believe you should fast for at
least 16 hours a day
coffee and water is okay during that
fast period
so like i said i like to eat between 10
and 6. today i'm doing a
18-hour fast
i like to eat between 10 and 6.
this is my usual routine and then what i
eat is also important and how much i eat
is also important i don't want to
overeat i don't want to under eat i want
to eat the right amount i want to eat
small meals i don't want to gorge i
don't want to fill my stomach up i don't
want to be
laying on the couch in a food coma i
want to eat the right amount in the
morning i eat every day eat oatmeal at
the afternoon i eat
high protein rice so like brown rice
mixed with uh
wild rice so it has high protein i eat
chickpeas or lentils or some kind of
a bean some kind of legume
with vegetables often as well a little
bit of fruit
and
i eat once in a while i'll eat a piece
of flesh
i'll eat fish or i'll eat shrimp or i'll
eat some kind of chicken sandwich or
something like that
does this include eggs
i love eggs one of my fa i could eat
eggs every single day i don't eat eggs
every single day but
eggs is one of the greatest
uh most enjoyable foods however i limit
them i have them
once a week once every two weeks
i think every single person in the
audience right now has the same question
what about the one gram of protein per
pound of body weight every day um it
depends what you're i really believe in
that i think that every time i've upped
my protein i've i've put on more muscle
and i really feel like especially i'm 40
now i don't want to lose muscle
so i'm more strict on that when i was
younger i didn't care so much and
usually some people say okay it's
0.8 grams of protein per pound of body
weight or 1.5 some research say even if
you bring it to 1.2 1.5 it's even better
you have a greater recovery uh i i
question the long-term effects of that
you know does it does it harm you in the
long term but i did definitely in my own
personal experience
um feel the difference that when i have
an adequate amount of protein that's
what i was telling i ate a high protein
rice
i i buy a rice that's a mixture of
wild rice and brown rice and that that's
high protein plus i eat a lot of beans
and lentils
and
i cook them i mash them i
also i've been doing it a long time so i
don't have any gas over over time you
don't have gas your body will get over
that
your body's your bio your uh your gut
health your gut microbes will change
and you'll foster more a gut microbe
that digests uh fiber
and you'll be you have a healthier gut
microbe
and
you want to eat
reasonable amounts if you overeat you're
going to feel lethargic if you under eat
you're going to feel hungry
and if you want to lose weight
if you want to lose weight
you have to feel a little bit hungry
you can't eat till you're perfectly full
you have to leave and here's the key
word
a little bit of hunger
in your system
don't starve yourself then you're just
gonna be weak
your willpower is gonna break
your body's gonna feel lethargic
you're going to lose muscle
you're shooting yourself in the foot
be
a little bit
hungry that's the problem with people
have when they say a little bit hungry
like okay i'm going to do even better
than what he said i'm going to starve
myself no
that's not what we want you're going to
slow down your metabolism you're going
to become weaker
you're in the long term going to make
yourself fatter what you need to
understand is i'm telling you be a
little bit hungry you know it's actually
sunnah
eat a third
fill your stomach with a third
then a third with water and the rest air
that's correct formula
don't be full
be satisfied don't be hungry
be satisfied so then a few hours later
you're going to be hungry again and then
you're going to eat and you have your
final meal and then in the evening
you'll be a little bit hungry but you're
gonna go to sleep you're gonna forget
about it you're gonna wake up your
body's gonna have chewed through the
reserves
so i mean i exercise every day to keep
the muscle on i eat high protein to keep
the muscle on but i also at the same
time
fast about 16 hours a day that works for
me and in the book uh and jason found's
work um everything you need to know
about fasting he shows you different
ways of fasting you can you can fast for
12 hours and eat for 12 hours that's a
good way to introduce yourself to
fasting i mean if you can't if you start
eating at 9am and you can't stop by nine
if that's too hard i mean you have no
willpower whatsoever like you really
have to start you know questioning
yourself you know what are your goals
like what's wrong with you like then you
got to make it 11 hours 10 hours eight
hours nine but
you should i'm comfortable with eight
eight for me is pretty easy
so i highly recommend you find a range
that's comfortable for you and then
slowly kind of shrink it down and eat
healthy make healthier choices your body
will lose weight your body will feel
amazing it's all a question about
taking it one step at a time one degree
of difficulty more
don't overwhelm the body by starving it
don't overwhelm the body by giving up
and just saying look since i'm not dying
i'm gonna eat everything i want you know
so it's the same thing as training
so let me play devil's advocate here
because
you had said that
the whole plant-based thing but don't
you think that there are certain people
who thrive on plant-based and certain
people who drive all animal based foods
um i would agree with you however
um
in my opinion
the research that's out there
even though it's based on
epidemiology i always have trouble
saying that word forgive me
it's still the best research we have and
it's
in my opinion
pretty accurate so for this for instance
if you look at the
longest living population
it's the okinawans
japan what do they eat well they eat
mostly vegan and once a month they eat
fresh foods
once a month on average they eat fresh
food
protein like animal flesh
the vast majority of the time they're
eating sweet potato which is one of the
healthiest things you can eat
vegetables and rice and whatnot other
carbohydrates they have a high carb low
fat diet
and they're the people who live the
longest and we have like you know
countless
we have an abundant amount of data that
proves this countries that eat low
levels of flesh food and high levels of
starch
low level fat high level starch live for
a very long time and they're lean
they're physically lean you know i love
how john mcdougall puts it he says look
give me the fat on your body and i'll
tell you exactly what you ate he says
the fat that you eat is the fat that you
wear
he's saying i could tell you if that fat
comes from a vegetable from an animal
product if what what kind of fat it is
if you ate chips or whatnot where you
got this fat what you put in your body
why he says if you have an abundance of
calories at the end of the day your
body's gonna your body stores fat more
easily
as fat then it does carbohydrates as fat
so there's a process where the body
could take carbohydrates and turn into
fat but he says look it's very difficult
for the body to do that it takes 30 of
the calories to consume to turn
carbohydrates into fat your body much
rather turn fat that you consume into
fat on your body
so i guarantee you if you raise your
carbohydrates and you lower your fat and
you eat the right amount of calories you
also have to not
overeat
okay
you will be physically lead and being
physically lean is the number one health
indicator
so according to the locals like joel
furman they say look if you want me to
tell you how long you're going to live
let me know what your level of visceral
fat is the fat you have in your organs
the fat you have in your system
fat
leads to disease
so if you're abundantly fat
and your your organs are fat you have
fatty organs
you have visceral fat you have fat
living inside you
you're shortening your lifespan
so if you want to live the longest time
read up the starch solution it's amazing
because he has a whole website giving
you all sorts of free recipes and it's
the most inexpensive diet in the world
in my opinion i've done so many diets
man
like i've even done the carnivore diet
where you eat meat every day
i've tried it all okay now i have
athletes that swear by the carnivore
diet you're right there's some people
who believe they thrive more on the
carnivore diet but i've never seen a
single person do the carnivore diet for
two three years in a row i have every
single carnivore guy i meet him i see
him in a restaurant eating rice and
beans and i see him eating spaghetti and
like like my one of my students jersey
beer he he does the carnivore diet he
cycles it but he can't do it non-stop he
has to have his mashed potatoes he has
to have his rice they always fold they
always want to reach for the bread
they can only do it for so long
okay of course if you do anything for
six weeks you're going to feel benefit
if you stop i don't know
if you stop eating candy bars for six
weeks you're gonna feel better if you
stop smoking for six weeks like anything
you can do anything for six weeks and
feel better but show me what you could
do for life for a lifetime it's a
lifestyle you have i think that an
athlete in our sport
because it's a glycogenic sport you need
carbohydrates
you know so
you know what's crazy my mind is blown
at just the amount of like
multifaceted multi-faceted knowledge
that you have mashallah and it's like i
i watched a recent podcast that you
recorded on cryptocurrency and bitcoin
and all that yeah and i'm just like man
we gotta get you back on for uh finance
yeah that's another great topic it is
i'm sure i hope you guys are buying
bitcoin oh i'm we're in there
but there's boron that's coming we're in
yeah that's good man and you know what i
think uh
charlotte keeps rising but i think
there's gonna be a pullback when there's
a pullback it's a good time to jump in
and
buy more of it and i think it's going to
be around here for i think bitcoin is
going to be around for well over a
hundred years so
uh it's not going anywhere
it's not going away it's not going away
anytime soon inshallah
okay sounds good
do you two have any questions
i have one that's been on my mind but
it's so like far gone but i'll ask
anyways
i often hear that people with like lots
of muscle mass um you know that muscle
mass affects them in their performance
in in physical combat sports would you
say that's true or is there only like
once you get to this level it really
affects it i think that i think it can
be true doesn't mean it is true some i
always tell people do the sport and let
your body decide how much muscle you
need
because the guy who goes and he wants to
create hyper he's he's bodybuilding four
or five days a week and he's taking
steroids to balloon up his muscles
there's a point of where there's too
much muscle that
your your your oxygen system your body
cannot your your cardiovascular system
could not produce the oxygen oxygen that
these muscles need you know you're not
able to maintain them in this endurance
so for instance imagine i was telling a
a a marathon runner hey i want you to
bulk up and go running i want you to
bulk up five days a week and he's like
wait i have to carry all that muscle
around to the i have to carry it with me
the whole way all the way you know let's
say you're doing 100 kilometer race
that's that's there's a there's a point
where
that muscle now is a detriment there's
too much muscle
so the same thing with boxing
less so for boxing but still at a level
you can have too much muscle however if
you do your sport your body will
naturally find the right level of muscle
you need
okay
do you have any questions for us man
[Music]
i mean i'd like to hear about your your
guys's fitness routine one by one here i
wonder mind if you guys tell me your
fitness and diet routine yeah okay what
do you guys do you got a few minutes
before my group so let's go oh no take
it away
well my fitness right now has been kind
of
uh altered since i haven't been able to
do mma for a bit
but it's it looks a lot like um
push pull legs and then i'll take a day
rest and i'll just continue that and
continue this cycle
and before i had a very structured
program
but now i'm finding like i actually
enjoy going in and then doing what my
body feels it really needs to in the
sense of like the push or the pull or
the legs
you know so i one day i might go in and
i do pull ups then the next time it's
pool i might not do anything in the
vertical plane what about cardiovascular
system
what about cardiovascular system
ah i'm dealing with um
quadriceps tendonitis i'm trying to heal
that at the same time as this groin
injury so i'm hearing you don't like
cardio that's why i can
my earphones are translating what you're
saying they're saying he doesn't like
cardio yeah you are right
[Laughter]
you are right
listen there's always a smart way to do
cardio but you need to do cardio you got
to build it i prefer you guys train like
a sprinter so you can do aerodyne you
know the airdyne the assault bike you
could do that 20 seconds on 10 seconds
off for 4 minutes but you got to hit the
heart man it's important to have strong
cardiovascular system for your health
for your energy you're gonna have more
energy to go and do your workouts your
push and pull
don't underestimate the power of a
powerful cardiovascular system
um you know what what system i really
like
i like crossfit for for
for fitness but
crossfit has two problems in my opinion
now i don't want to get into a debate
with crossfit is out there but this is
what i see the two fatal flaws other
than that crossfit is really really good
what's crossfit's two fatal flaws
now there are some crossfitters that
have understood that
there's there are these two flaws and
they've corrected it
but many crossfitters
especially the classic style
crossfitters fall into these two fatal
flaws one they have this thing they
encourage each other to go all out like
beat your record like you did this
workout three months ago try to beat it
today
go all out push yourself i don't believe
you should push yourself to 100 like we
talked about earlier 70 to 85 95
sometimes
and two they have another fatal flaw in
my opinion they use precision exercises
for endurance so sometimes they have one
workout i forget the name of it but it's
like clean and jerk 30 times for as fast
as you can for time so clean and jerk
for time do it as fast as you can well
if you try to clean and jerk 30 times
it's a hell of a workout that's for sure
but you're gonna you're gonna cut the
corners you're gonna you're gonna
compromise your your your your form to
shave off a few seconds and guess what
you're gonna injure yourself you're very
likely people don't know this but
crossfit has a high level of dropout for
injury there's a high level of injury in
crossfit
a cleaning jerk or a deadlift is a
precise
movement you never do it for time you
never do it for for speed
power exercises are to build power never
try to use a power exercise to build
endurance
so you want to build endurance today use
the aerodynamics that make sense use the
raw machine use the track use the air
use the treadmill don't use the deadlift
to build endurance so they're using in
their power exercises or strength
exercises to build the dirt don't
squats have to be done perfectly you
have a scalpel on one hand and you have
a chainsaw on the other don't confuse
the scalpel for a chainsaw
a cleaning jerk most people don't do it
correctly for
cutting in here but
i have to hit all right what's the is
that
what's that
correct yeah
yeah i have not hit also guys so i have
to leave because i only have like seven
minutes left
same psychology
thank you it's been an honor it really
has been honored to
spend these uh
these past few hours with you talking
about these things man i could hear him
talk all day
pleasure thank you so much hi bro thank
that makes a lot of sense uh bro because
you don't want to be mixing endurance
with power you want to be doing both
concordantly like you mentioned but not
one for the sake of the other well i'm
not against dead lifting properly slowly
and then going for three 400 meter run
that i'm not i'm not a problem that's
not my it's doing it for time let's say
let's say they make up a workout that's
like okay 10 deadlifts 400 meter run
repeat it five times for time
that means you have to deadlift fast
because you're trying no no no no no no
give me five perfect deadlifts with
pauses i'm not timing you
i want precision i want a scalpel
and then okay when you run i want you to
run precisely and the run i'll time you
but don't time the deadlifts don't time
the cleaning jerks don't time the bench
press everything has to be done
precisely perfect i'm building strength
here
it's okay to surprise your body with
some endurance work mixed with power
work just don't turn the power exercises
into endurance exercises this in my
opinion is a big problem it should be
addressed but i love the novelty of
crossfit like you can look at a crossfit
website hey i'm motivated to do that
workout tomorrow morning i'm going to do
it i'm going to modify it to what i like
but i like the spontaneity of it okay
today we're swinging kettlebell tomorrow
it's push-ups and pull-ups tomorrow i
like it i really like it i think it's
fun like i make my own crossfit workouts
but i never go 110
i always go the right level
and i never confuse a scalpel for a
chainsaw
rowing machine has a dif is a different
purpose than the barbell okay so if i'm
doing a plyometric i'm not going crazy
and killing my i never compromise form
i never use a power or strength exercise
for endurance i use them
and i can mix them with an endurance
workout sure like you can do
20 kettlebell swings perfectly properly
and then get on the airdyne bike for i
don't know whatever your goal is maybe
five minutes and and
do intervals that's fine
just don't rush through
a cleaning jerk or pull ups or do them
properly you won't injure yourself
and you'll get fitter than there
but i love the mix i love the novelty
because i'm not trying to get good at
fitness you know i love the fact that
they mix gymnastics track and field
uh powerlifting strength
power lifting olympic lifting i really
like these things
body weight training they put it all i
love it i love the idea but when you
when you try to tell them look these are
the two things i don't like they kind of
blow up on you because it's like some of
them get offended but look that's my
opinion
and
you know they have a tremendous amount
of people dropping out due to injury
and i'm all about avoiding injury
if you injured yourself you did
something wrong
yeah
um unfortunately i have to go as well
okay brothers
we just wrap this one up then
this has been tremendous
in your family hopefully we get to have
you again soon
be a pleasure insha allah so you know
okay
there's another thing too it's it's the
perseverance aspect too like we're more
willing to stick through with things
that we set out with an intention it's
impossible to have empathy for others if
you're not patient so my love bless you
for that first of all i agree with the
fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing
stocks shares bonds you want to be
investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic hamza andreas
we will go in with our final three with
brother
angel
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
um
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]